wenn ihr die wahrheit kennen würde dann
würde die wette hannover würden sturm
die la famiglia greift mich an
inwiefern sie stehen vor meinem
grundstück und zielen mit bogen auf mich
ok kommen löffelt freunde und willkommen
zu einer neuen folge vorbei kropp leben
zusammen mit dem mitglied der türen
sekte guten tag guten tag ändern ist
wir haben für heute wirklich tatsächlich
pläne wer hätte es gedacht
wir bauen jetzt nämlich erstmal
kakaobohnen und das war es auch schon
meine freunde damit ist die hölle
wir lassen jetzt nämlich eben schnell
wachsen damit wir hier du kannst du
schon mal wieder ab und wieder hinter
tegra was meinst du bist und dann haben
wir klar kakaobohnen ja klar sonst
könntest du nicht vermehren
du bist wieder hin und dann wieder ganz
fertig und dann freunde dann sind die
soweit diese kakaobohnen dass wir so
viele haben dass wir unsere ganze wolle
die wir haben färben können
genau darin brown diese braune wollten
wir dann den nutzen für die bahner
unserer besten spiele schauen dass wir
hier für die handwerks geld machen
wir hatten gedacht wir machen eine
kleine handwerks quelle der sturm waffe
und ich richtig epilepsie wenn ich die
ganze dann nicht bei jungen dagegen wenn
die augen geworden ich werde der run
zoom alt sumann mit
jetzt zog ina rixen schnupperlauf
gesetzt hubsi viele kommen wir einfach
hinsetzen der nur bad aufgesetzt wie
also wir werden jetzt aus diesem
kakaobohnen die wir haben die wolle die
wir haben in braune wolle färben werfen
wir deine rolle zu geben
ich hab' ich habe auch schon ein
bisschen gefeiert auch bohnen abgebaut
richtig späten typ ich den spitzen so
und jetzt nehmen wir nämlich die tricks
die ich habe und jetzt machen wir daraus
erst mal so viele männer wie geht also
ich habe jetzt drei club du musst
eigentlich im prinzip auch nur einen
machen und dann kannst du mit einem
anderen banner dennoch mal wenn du den
einfachen crafting box den komplett
nachziehen
ich habe jetzt drei banner und dann war
das nicht richtig heiß auf sie kommt aus
nur das sieht richtig gut aus das ist
dass das ist der offizielle banner der
handwerks gilde freunde
das ist sehr schön aussieht also das
heißt braucht es natürlich erst mal ein
reihenhaus und ich mir euch glauben wir
mal eine für mein haus jedoch voll cool
auch wenn man die sonne hand hält kannst
du nicht
leiter der gruppe unterstützt indem
handwerks gips kirche waren die
autofahrer jetzt mit dem banner ich
natürlich erst mal im haus anbringen und
dann müssen wir fleißig natürlich nur
ein paar leute eigentlich immer wieder
ein lächeln beginne wenn die handwerks
gelder in die handwerks bilder können
wir natürlich besonderen paar leute
fragen wie den bart trägt ihr die sie
wollen sicherlich jeder hat lust darauf
wieso ist so dass es nur wenig
verwundeten cook ist das so komisch
wo soll ich denn bei mir hier die bahn
am besten an bringen eigentlich so an
die türen direkt neben schön wenn wir
hier sieht apple nochmals an die saiten
müsste da da oder also hier dahin oder
oder oder sowas sollte mich ein bisschen
verwildert ihr aussehen würde ich gehe
auch mal kurz zu mir rüber und handy
fehlten mir fällt ein banner entrollt
einer eingesammelt von mir oder nicht
ich habe meinen wie soll ich denn nur
zwei also doch ein habe ich eingesammelt
ja okay dachte hier jedenfalls ich
wollte eigentlich noch ein bisschen
weiter bauen an dem haus aber zurzeit
ist echt somit mit vorproduzieren wieder
und über karneval und so konnte ich
jetzt nicht so viel weiter dran bauen
eigentlich gar nichts aber auch hier
sieht dann stellt ford f damit
integriert [ __ ]
ich hab den doch schön wild
zurückgeschrieben schild ja ich hab das
geschenk hallo umgeben
hallo also ich werde hier an der an der
an dem haus auf jeden fall noch weiter
bauen aber dann halt irgendwie off
spielen dann werde ich euch das wieder
zeigen wenn ich dann aufnehmen
aber jetzt geht erstmal darum dass wir
die handwerks gilde irgendwie etablieren
theoretisch könnte das hauptgebäude der
handwerks gilde oben drauf sein auf
meinem auf meinem grundstück selbst
davon stamme
bei uns können dass mein haus und dann
könnte man oben drin dass ein bisschen
hier so ein kleines kleines geld ein
häuschen
so gewähren wenn irgendwas irgendwas
nicht funktioniert oder von irgendwas zu
wenig da ist man sicher dann austauschen
denn wie ihr wisst zu geben die gab es
ja dann mal für auch um sich gegenseitig
auszuhelfen
das heißt wenn jemand da so ein bisschen
jobs hat demokratisch einfach
aufgestellt
wenn jemand einen job hat gibt man den
ab also es gibt ja viele leute ich
glaube ich wurde letztens von ender
crack oder so angeschrieben damit auch
ob ich aber für mich fahren soll
irgendwas und so was wird dann über in
zukunft einfach über die handwerksberufe
auf wenn die leute dabei sind dann kann
man die leute einfach engagieren die
nächsten nahmen bisher müssen was zu
fahren wo sie was bereitzustellen
genauso werden wir das machen okay wie
ihn etwa wollen wir das haus dann
aufbauen
ich glaube ich petra bauer als ich schön
dass ich ganz schön wie machen wir das
erst mal gucken wie werden die größe
wiese abstecken denn auch hier hoch
dümpeln das heißt wer dem klügsten wenn
hier der eingang wäre oder damit man
nicht immer durch den haus muss ja das
wäre super
da machen einfach mal so hier in einer
eingang oder zweier eingang nochmals
zwei engeln wir wollen nicht sparen und
ist auch schön wenn man wenn man da
nicht ein bisschen abspringen ich finde
es fantastisch ich finde das fantastisch
den eingang natürlich selbst
wahrscheinlich mit türen gestalten oder
wie soll ich das machen weil wir machen
das ist jetzt der falsche wieder mit
kann es hier aber wieder nicht klappt
nichts und ich würde sagen dass das
gebäude muss aber auf jeden fall in
sonnen alltäglich der planer genau das
immer dem du hast vollkommen recht
ich vertraue dir
einfach wörter die die ohnehin gut ja
gut also wie wertvoll herren von dir vor
der kasse die affäre an
okay okay okay gut
man müsste auch eigentlich noch so ein
wunderbares aushängeschild hier machen
dass ist die handwerksgeräte dann jetzt
gegründet ist offiziell als morgens wenn
das seines teams hierauf ist
ich sehe sehr sehr scheiß der ausbau
sollen wir machen halt viel output soll
ich mal ein bisschen was farben gehen
drüben hintergrund ich glaube was hier
so ein schöner einging habe ich weiß
nicht echt nicht wie man so was schön
gestalten kann oder so kann das machen
wenn du magst ich weiß so möchte es ja
gerne auch mal aber ich habe keine
ahnung wie das funktioniert wie man
irgendwie bauen kann oder ich meine im
zweifelsfall kann man da doch ob perfekt
wieder zuschauer einbinden denn wenn ihr
super baukünstler seid könnt ihr uns
beiden ja doch einfach mal links
zukommen lassen oder screenshots am
besten auf twitter oder so von bauten
die ihr gebaut hat und vielleicht lassen
uns davon inspirieren oder sowas in der
art zum beispiel das können ja super
viele leute gut oder wir machen sowie
commerce ein modernes loft einfach so
ich mache hier sonnensee hin jetzt der
so runter fließt hab ich grad richtig
lust drauf okay und wenn nebenbei über
ein thema reden können wir machen direkt
über über über
wir könnten ja mal versetzte von der
familie schwieriger fall
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich wurde
gerade eben auch mal wieder von einem
der wunderbaren insassen ein wenig wenig
wenig misshandelt und erkläre ich sag
mal so viel
vielleicht ist er was im aufbau gegen
die gute la familia
denn wer sich bis jetzt davon gesehen
habe ist es ja einfach nur großmäuliger
großartiges rom gestunken oder viel
dahinter steckt war ich schwer zu
bezweifeln muss ich sagen das einzige
was ich auch bisher nur gesehen habe
sind irgendwelche vagen vermutungen auf
twitter leute wie ich meinen look
gesundheit somit die entspanntesten
leute im projekt weil wir einfach die
wahrheit kennen wir kennen die wahrheit
bekannt die wahrheit ein wenn ihr die
wahrheit kennen würde dann würde die
werdohler hander weg eigentlich schon
over für viele die hätten gesagt neben
so kann ich nicht weitermachen aber wir
ziehen das halt durch und deswegen sind
also leute wie die la famiglia mit ihren
lehrern androhungen auch einfach nur ein
witz für uns ja das sind halt das ist
sowas wie als wenn sie behaupten würden
quasi die welt ist eine scheibe
und wir kennen die wahrheit die welt ist
die werde es nämlich zwei scheiben
untereinander kann man unter gibt die
welt der schweren patzer das ist eine
scheibe tief verlegt
ja also ich freunde ich hoffe ihr
versteht so ein bisschen was wir euch
hiermit sagen wollen vertraut nicht
allen im projekt das ist alles also
ziemlich fiese lüge sophie sofie kann
man halt schon sein
ich weiß nicht wer von euch jetzt
irgendwie meint er würde die wahrheit
kennen da können wir halt wirklich nur
sagen ihr kennt die wahrheit nicht denn
die wirkliche wahrheit ist könnten
glaube ich viele nicht verkraften
ja also ich meinen vielleicht werden
deswegen auch ein paar spiele gespielt
in zukunft nur ein bisschen mehr
man weiß ja nicht man kann ja einfach
nur vermuten was denn noch alles auf uns
zukommen wird ein paar dinge gebastelt
paar spiele gespielt wird auf jeden fall
noch gemacht in zukunft aber wenn man
genau die wahrheit kennen möchte müsste
man eigentlich
ich sehe schon das erste banner der
handwechsel das schön welche mühen es
wird aufgabe sondern an einem an einer
hauswand gesehen ich halte diese läuft
denn jetzt zu dir bin ich denn dumm ich
wollte eigentlich am einfluss fertig
machen wo bist du denn gerade was mach
ich suche gerade weizen für ein paar
schafe von rackserver die sind ein
bisschen wieder ausgebüxt und wenn es
hier einst gibt wer sich momentan so ein
bisschen ein bisschen nicht gutheiße ist
es dass im momentan irgendwie ab und ein
bisschen geprüft wird und bajramaj
spielt mag ich ja und da sind jetzt die
scharfen laufen die heim rallye ist ja
gar nicht so klasse in die ganze
verschwörung sache mit der mit der
wahrheit verbunden oder rami steckt ganz
tief von müsse meinte ich meine die
story dient jetzt ich erst mal wo ich
daran denke dass oder oder oder was
meinst du alles gut alles gut ich
bestimmt nicht das ist lässt er mich gar
nicht so involviert aber da habe ich
auch noch nicht so mitbekommen oder ja
wir sind man muss man muss ja auch nicht
aushelfen wenn so situation jetzt
erstmal nur amis ja nach wie vor ein
freund das muss man hier kann man ja
dazu sagen da kann man ja auf jeden fall
aber erstmal die ganzen sachen ein
bisschen geschenkt wo zur hölle kommt
hier gerade acht mit mut gehört ich
denke mir einfach nur so viele leute
denken einfach das was die sehen so ja
das ist so und so aber wenn man die
wirkliche wahrheit wüsste ja nee das
fordert das ist viel zu weit greifen das
thema dann wenn man jetzt einfach
eigentlich gar nicht von meinem leben
angekommen also wie gesagt alles zu
seiner zeit leute wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwie euch die familie an kogler die
la famiglia und die ganzen leute alles
kommt zu seiner zeit alles gut
der kopflose reiter ist voller blüte im
kopf aber ich lasse es mal des amazonas
terium der kopflose reiter der
interessiert mich der macht mir spaß
wer da gesehen haben
wer dessen nämlich immer noch unterwegs
und keiner weiß wie es ist ich verstehe
es auch nicht wie es denn sowas möglich
überhaupt um sichtbarkeit tragen richtig
kritisch was bist du denn jetzt hier
riesig es bei der hand wechselte wieder
weg worten ich will nicht wissen was sie
tat alles abläuft du momentan ich denke
die sind die sind aufmüpfig müssen wir
da müssen vorsichtig sein
heute schaffen
du musst geht mit den chart maigret wie
bitte geh von meinem grundstück ja ich
sage ja der ds aufmüpfig momentan da
braucht es einfach lektionen dass sturm
die la famiglia greift mich an
inwiefern wir stehen vor einem
grundstück und zielen mit bogen auf mich
ok kommen
rewe habe ich abgeschlossen geleistet
jetzt freunde das ist nämlich die
familie die gehen einfach hierhin deuten
was an und gehen dann einfach ich sage
ja leere drohung
das ist nicht mehr schön was ihr
passiert schießen ab dass das ist nie
das war jetzt echt ein angriff zeichen
dass ich find das war jetzt gerade
angriffs zeichen wenn die wirkliche
schon zu mir hin kommen die guck mal die
stand hier so mit ihrem bogen vale
standen hier so von einem sturm wie
stell dir vor du bist meine mutter stand
hier so ich hab keinen fall im ziel fiel
auf mich und an riesch ab und leistet
das ist genau die la famiglia wie man
sie kennt das dass das mache ich nicht
mehr mit freunde da will ich auf jeden
fall einiges ändern hier in dem müll
das ist das ist gerade jetzt jetzt
gerade ist ein bisschen kritisch egal
ich kümmere mich jetzt hier wieder um
einen meinen tollen tage wie viel
eigentlich finde ich schön
ich will ihm ein kleines so harmonisch
meisten würde in so ein bisschen
eigentlich am liebsten mit laufender
reinpacken aber
ach man ein bisschen bauen mir hier auf
dem boden haben jetzt endlich genug
dollar
wenn ich habe noch ein bisschen wolle
geholt ich werde mal kurz kurz noch mal
eins klonen glaub ich klar noch mal ganz
oben schnell schneller hohen davon zum
teufel kommt diese acht mit musik jetzt
her ihr cook habe ich auch gerade gehabt
dass im riechen merkwürdig ne ich höre
sie nicht sehe ich der jukebox contento
mit version 9.5 mission
ich möchte ja mission geladen
etwas ausprobieren kurz sekunde sekunde
im einspänner über banner ja wie
erwartet aber ich wollte gucken man
weiße banner mit links machen können
also weiße zu brauen indem man diese
klont was geht nicht
den braucht jetzt wieder cacau bonas
denn ich hab das weggenommen
ich hab das weg gibt ich habs gerade
noch gesagt jetzt gerade gesagt habe ich
nicht mitbekommen ich dachte es wäre die
la famiglia gewesene lernen hätte trauen
sie sich nicht das trauen sie die trauen
sich noch hier vorzustellen bogen
spannen kann schon ganz schön viel sex
sex sex sex momentan schwierig die
richtige zeit für verbrechen ja
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
hubert wo ist der box and is love on
next
dann sah ich war jetzt oder mache das
für die menschheit los gemacht und sie
ob sie nee nee lassen wer days ich hab
einfach daher gesetzt
es war immer mein versuch spanne warte
ich wir setzen jetzt irgendwo noch ein
spielball
unsere guten banner wir haben nicht so
viele haben so viele dass es reicht so
jetzt kommt er jetzt irgendwo ein banner
hin wo man ihn sieht auf der fähre ins
haus darum freunde das wasser wieder mit
dieser sehr chaotischen folge ist der
kurze zusammenfassung damit die
handwerks gegründet die wird jetzt off
screen wahrscheinlich irgendwann gebaut
oder im livestream oder keine ahnung war
und dann wird hier die handwerks bilder
entstehen und danach freunde heute kam
wirklich die kriegs ankündigung der
familie wir dachten erst so ja okay das
ist eine sprache aber als sie dann
wirklich bei mir vor der bude standen
auf mich gezielt haben und mich
abgeschlossen haben auf die halbe anzahl
der herzen runter gebracht haben
das fand ich dann echt nicht schön
deswegen das wird auf jeden fall noch da
wird noch einiges passieren
wir haben euch ein wenig was wir werden
gar nichts verraten eckig von der
wirklichen wahrheiten dass das wird doch
das wird noch kommen freunde des kommt
drin ist nach und nach wird hier immer
mehr aufbereitet welche spieler hier
gespielt werden unter anderem und dann
würde ich sagen schaut auf jeden fall
auch beim staffel vorbei weil wir dort
auch mal die eine oder andere sache
fabrizieren und dann sehen wir uns in
einem anderen video wieder pausen